I said to be back and I'm back cuz I
thought you saw the trailer for
terminator genisys Genesis with a wise
come out I think their comment believed
is that I'm gonna rip [ __ ] into this
movie because I love Terminator 2 and
this is not Terminator 2 and how do they
gonna be honest with you though I
enjoyed this trailer a lot more than I
thought I would because first of all the
trailer starts out and it shows the
future I was like oh [ __ ] it's the
future as described and shown in
Terminator 1 and to scorch sky
everyone's fighting all the time
everyone's fighting at night not like a
lot of daytime and downtime and a lot of
boring I'm looking at you I see you then
it shows John Connor played by that dude
from dawn of the Planet of the Apes was
really cool to see him get work cuz I
think he's awesome here's a guy we need
to send someone back in time to protect
my mother because the Terminator sent a
terminator back in time and so it shows
that one dude funny enough Captain
Boomerang the dude I was talking about
in the last video I did from this one he
plays Kyle Reese he's like I'll go back
and protect her and it shows him go back
in time he appears in an alley and I was
like whoa this is like a retelling of
Terminator 1 pretty much you hear the
voiceover from John Connors all right
Kyle when you find my mother she's going
to be weak she's gonna be afraid you
need to protect yeah I remember she was
a waitress and [ __ ] didn't become bad
until Terminator 2 it's just this big
truck crashing to the store wipes out
the hits this cop who turns out to be a
t-1000 she'll Sarah Connor played by
Daenerys Stormborn of the House
Targaryen she's like come with me if you
want to live bubble boom now soldier I
was like give him Kyle Reese in his
movies like no this is all wrong I came
back to protect you she's like yeah from
the Terminator sent back in time to kill
me yeah we took care of it he was like
wait it's just old Arnold he's like I've
been waiting for you there's young
Arnold er these are from Terminator 1
and old Arnold shoots them and you're
like [ __ ] and I was like oh oh oh you're
doing what JJ Abrams did with Star Trek
you're pretty way it's a sequel but it
dealing with time-travel the timeline
has changed somehow and now it's kind of
a reboot if you're confused think back
to the future - when old Biff took the
Almanac back to young Biff and so they
got back to 1985 like whoa this is an
alternate 1985 and then that I feel like
they're jumping on the bandwagon to do
what a lot of movies are doing because
it worked for Star Trek but also I liked
it in Star Trek and I like that kind of
smart thing to do so it doesn't undo
Terminator 1 Terminator 1 still happened
it is a sequel but it's also a reboot if
you want to see it that was kind of like
the new Star Trek does not negate the
other Star Trek movies although it kinda
does but you can watch the old ones
and watch three boots and then watch
those that chronologically it's a time
loop that you could still enjoy this one
altum Utley looks to be a retelling of
Terminator 1 with all the cool elements
of Terminator 1 and 2 fused into one
because there's a G 1000 in this movie
which makes me think theories there are
theories now here's my theory I don't
know this is true it might be [ __ ]
from what I saw in the trailer this is
what I think is happening all right you
think back to the beginning of
Terminator 2 Linda Hamilton's narrating
she says Skynet sent two terminators
back through time one was to wipe her
out before John Connor was born it fails
that the other was sent back in time to
wipe out John Connor when he was a kid
given that information in the very
important shot where it shows Arnold
Schwarzenegger carrying a little girl
with a bazooka remember that [ __ ] here's
what I think happened in the future John
Connors like they sent a terminator back
through time I need someone to go back
and protect my mother and Kyle Reese is
like I will he's like all right boom
zaps him back and then someone's going
to be like wait sir they sent another
terminator back through time he's like
all right well we reprogram a terminator
and we're gonna send that back in time
to protect me as a kid I remember
someone's gonna be like no they didn't
send the second terminator back to the
90s they sent it before that oh [ __ ]
they sent the t1000 that was going to go
after John Connor in the 90s via
Terminator 2 back farther to take out
Sarah Connor when she was a kid John
Connor was like alright well we're gonna
send the terminator back in time farther
to protect her which is why she's a
badass now she's not some waitress she's
been paddling around the t800 all these
years and that's why Arnold's old
because it's living tissue over the
metal endoskeleton so he's going to get
older because the tissues just
ultimately breaking down that's what age
is essentially I saw they're gonna do in
the movie I think so the t1000 in this
movie is the t1000 that was in
Terminator 2 and old Arnold in this
movie is the Terminator that he was in
Terminator 2 same characters just back
in time a little further
I think the t1000 was going after young
Sarah Connor and then Arnold showed up
with his bazooka and stopped it and
carried her off and they've been
paddling around ever since although
Arnold probably gonna be like iris is an
integral part of the future you and him
you bang and then you make John Connor
that's the savior of humanity so we need
to go there because the shopping mode
and take out the t1000 to find them so
you two can do the thing you bang her
and you you bang him you you took it at
it you bang each other do it do it and
she's gonna take one look at her really
I swapped divergent sure let's do this
right now he's gonna be like what the
hot chick from Game of Thrones I get to
work work work he hadn't easy being Kyle
razors or lucky bastard so all in all
I thought it was going to [ __ ] on this
trailer I thought like we did watching
the trailer and I was like all right
let's get this [ __ ] over when I was
watching it I was like that's the future
I know from Terminator 2 and only [ __ ]
it's like the best parts of Terminator 1
& 2 and they're doing the whole loop fix
it up at thingy all in all as a
terminator 2 fanatic I'm going to give
this movie the benefit of the doubt
right down to the fact that she says
come with me if you want Olivia I can't
tell you in Terminator 3 when yous like
come on if you want to live come on I
was like no John Connor no that's not
the phrase no no come with me if you
want to live there's just such an
important phrase in Terminator that I'm
glad it's in this movie for me [ __ ] that
ends at Terminator 2 that's my
Terminator like Terminator 1 Terminator
2 end over nothing happens after that
cuz it's all [ __ ] I saw the trailer
for terminator genisys have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you wanna see more the good idea to
see more